counting down on crime on the las vegas
strip that's a major focus for metro
police as they see more murders thanks
for joining us at 11 i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis the homicide rate
in the resort quarter has increased
tenfold over the last year orco man
alive in the strip with how police are
addressing this important issue orco
brian and denise metro police tell me
that they're working around the clock to
prevent murders on or near the las vegas
strip here and while they say most of
the issues this year happen between
april and august they're implementing
big changes to cut down on crime
we've been dealing with some
unprecedented crime captain dory corrin
heads up metro police's convention
center area command which oversees the
las vegas strip and he knows it's been a
deadly year we saw this massive increase
the latest numbers from metro show there
have been 10 murders in the resort
corridor through october 8 2021. in
comparison there was one murder through
that same point last year that's a 900
percent jump captain corrin says more
out of state criminals coming to town
during the pandemic as resorts reopened
has played a role but he adds the legal
system's handling of repeat offenders is
also to blame they commit another
aggravated assault and another
aggravated assault eventually they
commit a homicide so what's being done
to address the murder rate we really put
a lot of intelligence and analysis
together to figure out exactly where the
crime issues were happening we divided
up our normal areas into micro sector
beats captain corin says so far in 2021
metro officers have made around 44 000
stops on the las vegas strip that
includes about 8 000 arrests and more
than 600 guns confiscated we asked
tourists about this increased
interaction i think that police presence
does help
to deter crimes people resources time
was definitely going to help captain
corrin says that's the goal we're not
letting off on the pressure
metro says a positive note is that they
have one of the highest homicide
clearance rates in the entire country as
of october 8th 89 percent of this year's
murder cases have been solved reporting
live tonight on the las vegas strip orc
omana live local now